à l'est de saint denis à part et la vie
de sainte marie au xviie siècle des
pirates échapper à un naufrage grâce aux
prières qu'il avait adressée à marie ils
élevèrent this inédit fils en son
honneur
la route nationale 2 est surnommée la
route des laves car elle est
régulièrement traversé plus à l'est par
les coulées de lave du piton de la
fournaise qui se dirige vers l'océan
le parc du colosse est un parc aquatique
en plein air son nom vient de la légende
qui raconte l'histoire d'un esclave doté
d'une force inouïe
le colosse le nord est de la réunion
étant dépourvue de plage le parc
d'attractions propose aux familles de la
région un autre divertissement aquatique